the games have started to get a little
bit more competitive
um and and so our opening choices have
have brought into slightly more clear
reality or relief rather the
sort of difference between playing
solidly playing aggressively
uh let's continue here we go and ten
minute chess
is what we play uh and we
get okay so we got white against
adelaide classen let's go e4
[Music]
let's get the pen out
okay and we have been playing the danish
no need to deviate we have been getting
winning positions out of the opening
every game
um and this continues to stump most
people
below 1300 but now we see another e
takes d4 so c3
um dc and bishop c4 enters the danish
um black doesn't have to take on c3
and we've encountered yes so he does
take on c3 and here we see players
finally beginning to enter the main
lines
right around 1200 uh you know standard
rating on chess.com i would say is the
very rough threshold when we start
seeing more of the main lines than the
sidelines
um and hudson oh i'm happy to do it okay
so queen e7
but as i say that um our opponent
plays a very strange move so
i think that obviously black is
targeting the pawn but this is not a
good way to do it because no other
pieces are developed so what should i do
here
i mean no need to reinvent the wheel we
have an obvious move
yeah just knight takes c3 of course and
now we've got two pieces developed this
queen on e7
i've actually noticed this as a pattern
a lot of players
at this level really like to put the
queen on e7 and that that is one of the
most
pernicious developing moves you could
make because
you are obstructing the development of
the bishop and that's a big problem
and that queen is also incredibly
vulnerable the one thing that
justifies it potentially is the fact
that it x-rays the pawn right thinking
deep
dick and if we were to just go knight f3
here
nonchalantly which is the obvious
developing move
then d5 happens right that's the entire
concept
is this actually dangerous no because
we are we have such a big lead in
development that we actually want black
to play d5 we want black to open up the
center for us
i hope that our opponent will play d5 so
i can show you okay so
he doesn't he continues to push response
this is going to be a complete disaster
um you you can't abandon your
development like this um and this will
backfire in about three three to four
moves so what should we do we should
just castle
and we've been through this a million
times right there's no need to go crazy
with any kind of sacrifices simply by
completing your development
you are already doing yourself a huge
favor now this is where we need to
demonstrate a little bit of creativity
um d6 is not a bad move this is a luxury
lesser evil
we have two approaches here we have what
i would define as the
sort of straightforward brute force
approach
where we just try to sacrifice and blast
open the center
and that would involve doing what that
would involve playing e5
and in the event of d5 just sacrificing
on d5
i feel like that's a little bit unclear
i'm not convinced by that
so i have another idea now you guys
should all notice as do i that there's a
queen and a king on the same file i've
told you to pay attention to that very
carefully when it occurs
and that may seem like a moot point
because there is a pawn on e4 if there
was no pawn anymore we would play rookie
one but
we can try to yeah exactly we can play
rookie one
and as those of you with a keen tactical
eye we'll notice knight d5 is uh thank
you
devil of all knight d5 is what we're
setting up here
okay among other things among other
things like e5 like if he goes knight f6
which is quite likely actually
because he might be like okay let's
finally develop our pieces he walks
ironically the moment he starts
developing
is precisely the decisive mistake
although really the decisive mistake has
already been committed i don't think
there's any getting
there's any way to get out of this
yeah rookie rookie one is very patient
it's very very strong it sets up knight
d5
c d e d just spins the queen and it
makes e5
a whole lot stronger all right bishop e6
okay good move good move what should we
do in response you guys already know
well why did we play rookie one we
played it
in order to set up
bishop b3 you guys are playing you know
like a very old you know chess professor
bishop but this is a london system um
remember why we played rookie one we
played rookie one in order to sacrifice
a knight on d5 which isn't even a
sacrifice
because if you play c takes d5 then
there's e takes d5 now if we played the
e5 here that would mix up two plans
it would allow d5 and we wouldn't have
any clear way forward right and i'll
show that after the game
knight d5 i think is the principal move
here
well let me just write this down e5 is a
is is interesting and he immediately
takes which is
disastrous because after e takes d5 this
bishop is going to be lost
and once we take that bishop the entire
position just totally collapses
collapses in on itself i mean i hope
this makes sense i hope that the concept
behind knight d5 makes sense we're just
trying to open up the the e file
and just because he's put a bishop there
doesn't mean
uh that that this entire operation is
not worth pursuing is very much worth
pursuing he he just doesn't have any
pieces out
that's as simple as that there's no
other way to define it
um and we might be down upon i'm not
even counting the funds i don't care
doesn't matter um this is game over
you you can't get away with something
you just can't do that
and the entire time the queen on e7 this
placement of the queen just kills him
because he can't get the bishop out he
gets skewered by the rook and
yeah and he can't avoid just losing his
queen he takes f7 check
um now
this idea of knight d5 okay so knight e4
i mean just take it uh he wants this
okay so i see what he wants actually
that doesn't really help although it's a
creative defensive
approach i should have probably taken on
f7 first not that it matters
um not that it matters
okay i can peasant f6
so if you really want the bamboo stick
kind of move here right
the first thing i i see just and my
brain is trained to look for this
are these dark squares right the dark
squares are so juicy
how do we exploit them
that what do we exploit them with first
of all um 100 bits thank you yeah
oh knights are
you know the premier piece to exploit
weak squares with
knights are the screwdriver of chess you
can just chisel your way
into um you know these these small
spaces
and um in combination with the queen the
knight is an absolutely lethal tandem
the light squares are really really good
oh did i say dark squares yeah i meant
the light squares
that is a sexy move indeed and you'll
see this often in more
double-sided positions you know this
idea of
getting the knights of one of these
squares it doesn't even matter where we
go
um we can go for his rook
but we don't even have to we can go
directly for head on apply directly to
the forehead
we'll go for his rook here just because
i don't know i think it'll make him
resign faster
but this kind of stuff it really doesn't
matter you don't you don't need to
you know drive yourself crazy trying to
find
the computer continuation just take his
rook we're up a rook and a piece and
it's time for him to resign all right
check
yeah now he's got to go to d8
we can give him a check on f7 although
that would be quite uh kind of
counterproductive because that would
allow him to tuck his king on c8
the best would be to get the queen into
f7 that way we would be threatening
immediate checkmate right
yeah and we'll i'll all as i always do
i'll answer the questions after the game
let's finish our development here bishop
f4 he correctly goes king c8 the funny
thing is the game drags on a little
while longer
um and this is yeah okay
i'm not sure what he's hoping for here
no i mean there's no mate but
you know like how do we actually win
this position some of you may
choose to take his pawns here and just
promote that's possible
knight g6 is possible i always like to
move like rook c1 just bringing all the
pieces in
and that's a good good rule to live by
just
the more pieces you bring in to the
attack no matter how many extra pieces
you have the better off you're going to
be in the end
so okay g5 just drop the bishop back
and i know it looks like why are we not
mating him faster
as my first coach would always say
do they record on the results score
sheet
how many moves the game took and you
know it was a rhetorical question
obviously and i was supposed to say no
and the sentiment was supposed to be
that you know you're supposed to be
patient and how you convert these
positions
okay
of course i understand that but even but
even for a 1200
i think this is a resignable position
okay
no i mean this is just rook c6 is coming
in this is a pin
not much to talk about in this position
okay i mean the funny thing okay so
let's find the fastest mate
no let's not let's just take all of his
pieces
thank you ror 2008 18.
i'm just gonna exchange
yeah queen b6 queen b7 and b4s mate
yeah i mean okay come on queen b7
get over here
all right finally we deliver checkmate
um
play this out to see if i was reportable
yes oh my lands we got reported
so this is a very big mistake and
i think the impulse is is understandable
queen e7 isn't always bad and
ryan i'll i'll play you next um i'll
play you next
and then we'll and that'll be my final
game
but uh you know the damage that this
move does is is tremendous particularly
given that you're already
behind in development now a little bit
later i will talk about the proper way
of playing here but not right now
so knight c3 c6 that is actually not a
bad move
and okay so let's talk for a second
about d5
right we can't take on d5 we drop the
bishop back d take c4 a lot of people
would reject this because black wins a
second pawn
but you have to see the bigger picture
here black is opening up the center
which is a great thing for white it's
black is also helping you open up this
bishop so what would be white's like
simplest move here and literally you
just play according to the formula you
know what to do and there's a bishop on
b3
you can castle and give up the knight
but even simpler than that no need to
even calculate
that no need to calculate that
now you guys are falling for this
remember that bishop e6 is always
something to reckon within these
positions knight g5
is what i'm thinking of threatening
knight f7
no good way to defend it then we castle
would then we pick up the pawn go rookie
one
um it's going to be a massacre down the
e file
all right um so this is crescent uh so
h6 castles d6
and yeah um e5 d5 would be the other
approach but i actually couldn't
make this work entirely we could
sacrifice like this
but a position like this is actually
quite a bit more double-sided than it
may seem
so it's that's far from clear that's why
we chose rookie one
what if black pushes e3 where
oh you mean here well e3 doesn't do
anything i mean e3 you can just win the
queen like this
or you could even just take on e3 that
doesn't actually do anything
all right so he goes
wait sorry he goes h6 um too many pawn
moves obviously d6 rookie one and now
the king of knights e5
and the decisive mistake cd loses
immediately the
interesting bit would have happened
after queen to d8
and um the funny thing is this knight on
d5 right
it's it's a good night but in and of
itself it doesn't win win you the game
you have to have a supporting cast here
how do you build up the supporting cast
what should i do in this position
and the first thing you should realize
is that black doesn't threaten c takes
d5
you still have e takes d5 so you don't
need to worry about that not being
hanging it's not
what should you do there's a very sexy
well there's a very nice move here
who can find it not not the easiest move
to spot so this is fine
all right bishop f4 is a b-plus move
bishop f4 is a b-plus move
but i think you guys would agree with me
black plays knight d7
black can slowly start to untangle the a
move is knight d4
yeah okay now there's a very concrete
idea
and a very concrete idea is revealed if
black plays knight d7
tragedy is going to strike boom the
moment the f7 pawn departs from this
square
this diagonal weakens the knight covers
e7 this is checkmate right
um so that's the threat this threat is
very hard to defend against
and if you move the bishop away now the
e file is wide open and only now is the
time to go e5 look at how overwhelming
this position is i'm not calculating a
single variation and i can tell you
without an
inkling of doubt that this is probably
like plus 20 or probably maybe even like
you know forced to mate maybe e5 is not
the most patient but
i i can guarantee you that this is
completely winning okay
so this is just absolutely crushing
tyrox thank you for the prime and moves
like knight d4
are you know they're very easy to miss
they're very very synonymous and the way
that you
the way that you find them oftentimes is
is to realize that
immediately when you're ahead in
development you have a big development
advantage
um you can sometimes afford to move the
same piece more than once so if there's
something specific that you want to get
done
such as eliminating this bishop from e6
that is a
that is a bigger priority than
completing your development sometimes
all right so he takes on d5 and the game
ends immediately
i mean after ed and we don't have to
look at the rest
boom take it knight h4 and
and then it's just totally and
absolutely crushing
um 100 bits from magon thank you and
tyrex for the print any questions
i'll play uh ryan next
okay
all right
no it's not immediately obvious and we
got a white game against ryan
and let's go e4
okay so we are facing a car con now
um this is an interesting dilemma
because
i i professed to play very aggressively
and
the most aggressive line against the
karaoke without a doubt
is the fantasy variation that is what
we're going to play
now i i don't love this from the
perspective of teaching
beginners um because the fantasy
variation
involves making a certain move that
people have a certain relationship with
and that move is of course f3
yeah okay
so d takes e4 f takes c4 the point of
the fantasy
is to preserve the center and also to
open up the file as we did here ryan
is already playing it way too passively
he's got e6
he's blocked the development of his
bishop he's allowed us full control over
the center and now the development is
going to be
very very natural now we can go knight
f3
now where should this bishop go
all right
so some of you saying c4 don't bite on
granite yep
gym d3 is much better now we just castle
so we're making simple developing moves
and black's position is still quite
solid we shouldn't go
crazy here but we've got a just a
phenomenal
position all right now
here again we don't need to reinvent the
wheel we can play knight c3
just continue developing our pieces
um but we don't we don't have to
that's not the only way that we can play
it yeah so this movie e5 some of you are
thinking of
i wouldn't rush that movement what is
the russian playing e5
what could end up happening is you allow
him to play c5 and undermine
the center so let's let's go with knight
c3 let's let's first develop our pieces
he's not going to go e5 and the
blender's a pawn
okay now that he's castled now uh it is
high time for us to
open up this bishop and and play e5 now
you might be looking at this and saying
what do you mean open up this bishop now
it's like staring at the knight
well yes but um this knight could later
be dislodged
and i can be dislodged a lot faster than
perhaps some of you
may realize and hopefully i'll get a
chance to demonstrate this
there's a very typical plan in such
positions uh
that that is precisely aimed at
dislodging such a night and i can show
you
many real-life examples of this and
we'll we will get a chance to
demonstrate it
now this is kind of complicated and
some of the logic behind this i'll
explain after the game
the skeleton that you guys should all be
able to see um when i say dislodge a
piece you should immediately be thinking
of pawns pawns are like the mercenaries
that allow you to reliably get a piece
off of a square because every minor
piece
every heavy piece they all have to res
they all must honor
um being attacked by a pawn and so
the move here is h4 that's not the only
move and ryan immediately responds with
queen b6 that's actually a super
tricky move that is a super tricky move
so in
answer to h5 we notice that he is
skewering the pawn
which means that knight g takes e5
becomes possible
so we need to play in a much more
measured way here what should we do here
well we can move our king away
that would be fine in order to get rid
of the the pin
um in fact that might even be the best
move
but if we want to do something kind of
five head
wait let me think about this for a
second
yeah so there's some really cool lines
here after queen e2 he's got a he's got
a cool tactic
um let me write down why so queenie two
is not the best move and i'll show you
guys after
yeah so i initially thought of this but
after the game i'll show you why
we're not going to go for this and um
let's indeed stick to stick to our guns
stick to our initial guns and let's move
the king away king h2 king h1 doesn't
matter which one
getting rid of okay knight i take c so
now we take and
this is an undefended bishop we have
accomplished our goal the bishop now has
a direct line of communication with the
spawn
and some of you may fall in love with
the concept of taking on h7
and then playing queen h5 but always try
to get the order right why do that
when you can directly play queen h5 and
fork the pawn on the bishop
the game is essentially over so
this idea of h4 may seem particularly
uh crazy to some because well because
we're moving pawns with h-bond on the
same side
as your king like what kind of lunatic
would do that and yet it's perfectly
justified trust me now here this is a
great example of not
rushing and always looking for the best
move so
we could take the bishop and we're
completely winning but in the name of
playing
daniel style playing insane chess what
if we just
looked at this for a second and said
wait a second do we even need to take
this bishop
what if we get directly down a business
down to the business of checkmating
bishop h6 is
just a no-brainer attack and look at all
these pieces accumulated on the king's
side
we don't even need this bishop now this
is something you shouldn't do
um unless you're absolutely confident
that
this is going to work because taking the
bishop would be the safe option we're up
a piece and then we could play bishop h6
at our convenience
i'm just trying to show you guys the
process
right the process of not playing moves
automatically that's important
this specific instance where we play
bishop h6 is not as important
yeah he's dead queen d8 okay
now we have a very pretty move i mean we
have several pretty ways to win the game
who can see it
so what's the logic what's the logical
processor yeah bishop g7
or bishop g5 um the logical process is
to realize that queen h7 is going to be
checkmate we need we need to move the
bishop
and as i always say we need to do as
much damage as possible with that bishop
and we can do a lot of damage by winning
the queen bishop g5 or just like winning
everything else
this is the fastest mate maybe he can
stave off the mate with a couple of
moves here um let's see if he finds them
but not for very long okay
um let me
see if i can find for you guys
some real life examples of this h4
concept oh
i know exactly what to show you i'll
show you guys a couple of things here
you're in for a little finale finale um
treat
good game ryan that was awesome
um that was awesome and a very
instructive one i think
so fantasy variation
um was first played in the year 1890 by
max harmonist that was his last name
harmonist
his pieces were always well placed they
were always in harmony against
uh the one and only kurt von bart eleven
and kurt von barton 11 is known for
playing
a very famous game of course against
wilhelm stein it's right the rookie
seven or f7 game um and barton
bartle 11 seemed to be on the losing end
of a lot of these games he lost this
game as well
and you know the the the
and a lot of um marozzi played f3
tardikar alakine played f3 a bunch
these were very forward-thinking people
because to play up three
and to realize that it's okay to weaken
your king like this
is you know quite forward thinking and
it still is one of the most reputable
lines against the carl
it's experienced a resurgence in recent
years it's called the fantasy variation
now i have previously gone on record and
said that if you're a beginner and
you're looking for a good line against
the karo khan
uh the exchange with bishop d3 not only
is this a good line objectively
sorry not only is it gonna line
practically it's objectively considered
right now i think to be
one of white's best tries for a slight
advantage thank you andy miller
um now what is the point of f3 well
obviously to preserve the center that's
that's it
that's all there is to it you're trying
to preserve the center
and you know ryan i'm
i sympathize because it's very hard to
figure out what to do here if you've not
seen this before you haven't studied it
black has a million
different setups here all of which are
okay
the uh old school line is to play d take
c4 and then e5
and of course if white just myopically
takes on e5 then
you fall into the damiano trap that's
not what white's supposed to do here
white goes v
on again but still knight f3 bishop c4
sort of quickly developing it's the same
spirit of
gambit playing then you get super sharp
positions here that are a little bit
beyond the scope of what we're
discussing right now
um but i think that in this position
after knight f3 one of the best moves
according to modern theory
is to play them with bishop e6 this is
actually not that common
but if you want a little bit of an
inside scoop this is a good move
it looks a little bit weird right like
wait a second knight takes c5 but again
remember there's queen h4 check
and d take c5 is just never dangerous
because it ruins white's pawn structure
it gives the bishop
a beautiful square on c5 you don't even
have to worry about winning this pawn
out immediately
there is also moves like queen b6 which
are quite dangerous yes that is also
possible
[Music]
and black can play g6 here as well black
can play even e6 here
but the combination of taking an e6 ryan
that is a little bit passive
because you're giving me the entire
center the f file and you're closing
down the bishop which is understandable
um so
yeah but e6 your move has been played in
70 games so
even some pretty decent players have
played so knight f3
um you know this this has happened
before many many times and 97
was played twice um
interestingly enough now that's an
understandable maneuver i don't think
this is bad actually
all right yeah i played the tall
variation in the advance now any
questions thus far
any questions thus far
yeah okay
exactly so bishop d3 knight g6 castle's
bishop e7
um knight c3 developing now one thing to
consider in such positions
ladies and gentlemen is uh the
possibility of c3
this gave me some pause
um and sometimes you want to do this
where instead of putting the knight on
c3
you create a little bit of a pawn chain
just so your center is a little more
solid
and the way that you could go around
this is you could play bishop e3 and
then i be to d2 we've seen this before
so i'm just trying to expose you guys to
the various ways in which you can
complete your debt you don't always have
to put your head down and go nice
between that f3 bishop d3 bishop b3
the knight on c3 um is
is that is usually the best placement
for the knight but the knight is often
also good on d2
now the most interesting moment in the
game
okay here the movie 5 is pretty darn
obvious i would say right we're opening
up the bishop
but that is only good provided that we
can get the knight out of g6 now if i
were you ryan i think c5
was probably your best chance here i
think c5 was probably your best chance
okay because in light of what happened
after this you have to try to create
chances in the center
and i would have just taken on c5
and after bishop c5 king h1 black is in
trouble here without a doubt
but at least you get a little bit more
activity for your pieces i mean you
should see this right
um not like you should see c5 but in
this position you should see that
at least black can play and
97 understandable you're developing your
piece i mean
every move you played was perfectly
logical so
i sprung the fantasy on you that's a
hard line to figure out what to do it i
i mean so i appreciate you being game
for this
and now the move h4 right so
um here is
a game that i played in 2014 a rapid
game
in a position that may seem entirely
unrelated entirely unrelated
um give me a second it's a chess spacing
i'll show you guys two
illustrative examples here from
different
different sources i would say julio
sedora
grand master um i'm playing black
and this is a nimso indian you know sort
of a
positive position whatever random
position get this position right
and black's position is a little bit
past although it's a semi-semi-slop
structure
and in this position what do you guys
think that being the psychopath that i
am being the complete psychopath that i
am um this is a classic daniel move
what do you think i did
right yeah it's right
so
there's two things to understand here
the first is the conceptual underpinning
why can you get away and this is a
frustration i think a lot of and i don't
want to put words in anybody's mouth
but i think that this is a frustration
felt by some beginners and intermediate
players as you guys watch
top gyms like why can they get away with
violations of these rules
and the bottom line is that this rule
about not pushing pawns in front of your
king
should be taken with a serious grain of
salt
the king is very safe on g8 just because
you're pushing pawns in front of that
king doesn't
automatically grant white some sort of
mythical attacking powers
white is nowhere near um
getting an attack against my king and i
still have this this exoskeleton fully
intact
so don't um over
generalize this and now consider moves
like these concretely rather than
um as part of some sort of general rule
like oh we go h5 so your king is now
incredibly weak
the second thing to understand the idea
here is very simple you want to dislodge
the knight from g3 kick it away
and it has no good place to go and if it
goes back
then this bishop opens up creating
attacking chances for black
and if knight takes h5 then just as in
the game knight takes h5 bishop takes h5
identical concept we've succeeded
and now we go queen h for uh forking
uh the bishop in the pawn so my opponent
went f4 which is a which is a really
interesting move he's also pushing upon
in front of his king and he's trying to
blunt the bishop in preparation for hr
which i played anyway
and then i struck with c5 i got a really
nice position here that night
took a while getting back in the game
and uh so i took this opportunity to
sort of open up the position
um so you will find that this idea of
kicking away the knight on g3 or g6 by
pushing the h-pawn
is actually a is actually very very
common
and i just remembered another game that
i played a couple of years ago
um when i was just becoming a gm let me
see if i can track it down
yes i can and in this game
in this game yeah campos moreno
so i was i was um i was in i am
and it was another nim so that was the
stage when i played the nimzo indian
together with the king's indian
and um here is another
a good example of that right so
first of all we reach this position and
i was thinking okay this is an iqp
now with an iqp isolated queen's fund
position what's very important is to
keep the square in front of it under
control
this knight on g3 where does it want to
go
where does this knight on g3 want to go
and for what reason
oh
boom step one
castles now step two guess what i did
and for what reason i really really want
this bishop on f5 wouldn't that be juicy
attacking the queen
then i played rook c8 great position
there's a knight on g3 and it's stopping
me from doing it
i don't want to go bishop d6 in bishop
g3 that's ridiculous i don't want to
weaken the dark squares
so what do you think i did bingo
h4 and he had played b4 out of a little
bit of panic
and i win the pawn and the game ended in
a draw i failed to win
but the plan was successful so here you
see this idea applied not for an
attacking reason
but simply for the positional reason of
getting the knight out of g3 that's an
inherently good thing
um and once again i've pushed a lot of
pawns in front of my game but black's
king is still okay
black's king is still doing just fine
because there's no pieces there
and um yeah
can okay so can white go h4 now if white
goes to h4
then that pawn on h4 is a lot weaker
than its counterpart precisely because
the knight on g3
doesn't allow white to go g3 himself and
black can go knight g4
and this is horrible because now that
we're he's going to lose the pawn
and the whole position collapses
um i hope that makes sense
so here are some examples um and i
didn't mean to just show my games but uh
this is what came to my mind
of similar ideas and now you can see
that this is not
some sort of outlandish and incredibly
uncommon idea
um and that is not to say you shouldn't
be careful about
pushing a pawn in front of your king you
absolutely should
um whenever you play a move like this
you need to weigh the positives and the
negatives
the situation here is complicated
because after queen b6 king h1
now knight h4 drops a piece as happened
in the game
but ryan if you had taken a on an h4
immediately
then uh queen h5 no longer wins a piece
because uh the queen on d
defends the bishop right so
what should we do here for white tricky
question for you guys
queen h5 doesn't win the bishop should
we play quinn h5 anyway
is it worth it why why not and if not
what else should what else can you offer
okay it absolutely is worth it yes that
was a bit of a trick question
because after you lure black into
playing g6 and that is the only move
because f5 there's a non-facade
h6 you already know how to respond to
that
look at these dark squares and that is
the whole point of h4 we get our queen
into h6
and now we're gonna go 94 and district
g5 or maybe rook four depending on what
he does
and black is busted here completely and
totally and utterly busted
the dark squares are incredibly weak
black is falling apart
all right so that's the secondary idea
of a choice it's not just some gimmick
to win a piece
the bottom line is you're trying to mate
black on h7 if h6
then you already know from the game that
the move is bishop takes h6 blasting
through the gates
white has an overabundance of attacking
pieces
all right uh so queen b16 h1 now the
last thing is if we had gun queen e1
um the sam shanklin question comes in
handy queenie one defends against
uh knight takes c5 right because if h5
the knight e5
can't take because of the pin it's very
logical to defend
uh e5 what happens if we do it anyway
well wait a second well we thought we
had knight takes c5
but in comes queen takes d4 check boom
boom
fork black is up two pawns and just like
that the tables turn
so that is the power of that question
what happens if we do it anyway
you all force your brain into
considering this option
and then the rest becomes pretty easy to
calculate okay
um so that's the reason we we dropped
our king to h1
yeah but now you can play bishop e3 yeah
but but that how does that help
because bishop e3 queen takes c5 and
black is have two pawns
how does black react afterwards when the
black is busted after pin h5
like already in this at this position
black is in big trouble
now i think that maybe the last chance
was to counter strike in the sound with
c5
and i will finish this game with this
um advice uh that i don't know how
common it is i mean
again i'm not fully aware of
the sort of you know what you guys are
learning right now but
when i was kind of growing up there was
this very commoner frame
meet a move on the flank with a blow in
the center
right any move on the on the side of the
board like horse should often be met
with a cr with a blow in the center
and that is a lot of truth to it so when
you see a move like h4
or g4 that tends to strain
your opponent's resources and it tends
to weaken the position
and um the move c5 is logical from the
point of view of undermining the base of
the pawn chain trying to get more
activity for black's pieces
and kind of complicating the game
um okay so h4
that's that idea and that was a great
game ryan i think that was a
very rich game and i really really
appreciate
uh you playing and of course
the rest of the game straight forward
though it was
just pointing out that we could have
taken the bishop but this is even more
straightforward
[Music]
you